توتر متصاعد
و قصف متبادَل بين الجيش الأوكراني
وانفصاليين موالين لروسيا،
ما لذي يجري يا ترى؟
روسيا تطرد نائب السفير الأمريكي من موسكو!!
قصف مدفعي ثقيل
من إقليم دو نباس يطول بلدة أوكرانية.
هل اندلعت شرارة الحرب العالمية الثالثة؟
هل كان انسحاب القوات الروسية
هو الهدوء الذي يسبق العاصفة؟
اتهامات بين الطرفين
حول من خرق اتفاق مينسك،
والنتيجة قد تضر العالم بأسره
وأوكرانيا تدعو إلى إدانة دولية
سريعة للقصف الروسي ..
لكن لماذا إقليم الدو نباس
وليس غيره من المناطق،
ما الذي جد اليوم في القضية الروسية الأوكرانية؟
(بداية الحرب)
في خبر عاجل لكنه كان متوقعا،
خرج وزير الخارجية الأوكراني
ليعلن أن روسيا بدأت بخرق الهدنة،
وقال: أن قصف مدفعي ثقيل
من إقليم دو نباس يطول بلدة أوكرانية
في لوغانسك، هناك دعا الوزير
جميع الشركاء إلى الإدانة السريعة
لانتهاك روسيا الخطير لاتفاقية مينسك....
فهل بدأت الحرب حقا؟
على الطرف المقابل..
رد الكرملين، أن الوضع في دو نباس
يتصاعد ولدى القوات الأوكرانية هناك
قدرات عسكرية هجومية ضخمة،
وأكد الكرملين أيضا
أن الناتو يشن عدوانا إعلاميا مفتوحا على روسيا...
هنا وعلى الرغم من القصف المدفعي
لكن الأمر يزداد تعقيدا على وسائل الإعلام،
فما الذي يجري؟
موسكو أيضا قررت طرد نائب السفير الأمريكي
لديها من أراضيها، في تصعيد خطير
ومتعمد ردا منها على تعامل أمريكا
مع ديبلوماسيتها، بينما تتوعد واشنطن بالرد....
يقول المراقبون..
أن أمريكا شككت في مزاعم روسيا
بسحب بعض من قواتها على الحدود الأوكرانية
وأن الحقيقة هي زيادة ٧آلاف جندي
وليس انسحابا أبدا..
مقابل انكار روسي جاد لهذه الاتهامات...
(الحرب الإعلامية)
حرب باردة بالتوازي مع بداية الاشتباكات
في إقليم دو نباس...
الانفصاليون يقولون إن قوات كييف
قصفت أراضيهم بقذائف،
فيما اتهمت الحكومة الأوكرانية بدورها المتمردين
باستخدام المدفعية. بينما تنفي  السلطات الأوكرانية
قصف مواقع الانفصاليين..
والقضية تتعقد أكثر فأكثر!
تصريح أوكراني آخر
لصحيفة تليجراف البريطانية يقول :
رغم حقيقة أن مواقعنا تعرضت
لإطلاق نار بأسلحة محظورة،
فإن القوات الأوكرانية لم تفتح النار
ردا على ذلك”
..
ليقول بعد هذا كله وزير الخارجية الروسي،
سيرغي لافروف، أن روسيا، ستردّ الخميس
على الاقتراحات الأميركية بشأن الأمن في أوروبا...
مؤكدا أن روسيا  تطالب بضمانات أمنية
من واشنطن وحلف شمال الأطلسي...
فهل تتحقق مطالب روسيا ويكفي الله العالم
شر حرب لا تبقي ولا تذر؟،!!!!!
...
(إقليم دو نباس )
لكن لماذا دو نباس تحديدا؟
يقع هذا الإقليم جنوب شرق أوكرانيا،
على مساحة تقدر بحوالي 52 ألف كلم مربع،
ويضم منطقتي دونيتسك ولوهانسك
على الحدود مع روسيا.
دو نباس هو سلة الصناعة والغذاء في أوكرانيا،
فهو مخزون
لثروات طبيعية
وصناعات ثقيلة ومساحات زراعية،
كما أن الإقليم غني بمناجم الحديد
والفحم المستخدم في المصانع ومحطات توليد الطاقة والتدفئة
استطاعت روسيا السيطرة على الأقليم
من خلال سلطة موالية لها حتى عام ٢٠١٤،
برغم وجود أغلبية أوكرانية هناك...
...
وبعد أحداث ٢٠١٤
وفرار الرئيس الأوكراني السابق،
فيكتور يانوكوفيتش، إلى روسيا،
ضمت روسيا القرم إليها، وبدأ الحراك
في منطقتي دونتسيك ولوهانسك،
وتحول الحراك إلى شكل مسلح
ليسيطر المسلحون الموالون لروسيا
على المواقع الحكومية،
وهناك تم الإعلان من طرف واحد إقامة
(جمهوريتي دونتسيك ولوهانسك الشعبيتين)...
لكن لم يعترف بهما أحد حتى روسيا
الداعمة للانفصال لم تعلن اعترافها بهاتين الجمهوريتين...
من هناك بدأ الصراع المسلح في منطقتي دونيتسك
ولوهانسك وأدى إلى مقتل 13 ألف أوكراني
من بينهم 8 آلاف جندي.
أطراف كثيرة تريد إيقاف الحرب
وأطراف أكثر ستتضرر إذا ما اندلعت هذه الحرب،
فإلى أين المصير يا ترى بعد التقلبات الدرامية
في المواقف وردود الفعل؟
ما لذي يخبئه القدر لروسيا و أوكرانيا
ومن خلفهما للعالم أجمع؟